premio nobel de la paz y como la conocen
en mianmar la madre de la nación aún son
sus hijas también una figura
internacional de gran reconocimiento de
familia acomodada su padre fue uno de
los próceres de la independencia de
mianmar del imperio británico esto le
permitió viajar y conocer otras culturas
estudió en la universidad de oxford
donde conoció a quien sería su marido el
historiador michael davis en el
compromiso estableció que si el pueblo
la necesitaba ella cumpliría su deber en
1988 volvió a viajar para cuidar a su
madre su regreso coincidió con la
revuelta contra la dictadura de ne win
la dama como la conocen los hermanos
participó en las protestas y se
convirtió un líder de la liga nacional
por la democracia tras la revuelta fue
detenida y estuvo en prisión por 15 años
en diferentes períodos entre 1989 y 2010
su liderazgo fue reconocido
internacionalmente con el premio nobel
de la paz en 1991 tras su salida de la
cárcel en 2016 la liga nacional para la
democracia obtuvo una gran victoria
ella lideró al país consejera de estado
ya que la constitución beta la
presidencia a quien tenga parientes
inmediatos extranjeros empezó entonces
su mandato con unas sombras que luces
fracasando en el proceso de paz con
guerrillas set no nacionalistas e
incapaz de democratizar el país
especialmente cuestionada por la
limpieza étnica llevada a cabo bajo su
mandato por el ejército y la policía que
acabó con el desplazamiento de más de
700.000 rohingyas y dejó miles de
muertos pese a todo en 2020 en las
elecciones su partido liga nacional por
la democracia volvió a arrollar
empezaron entonces las acusaciones del
ejército de fraude que desembocaron en
el golpe de estado del primero de
febrero de 2021 cuando fue apresado